alors moi je considère que la politique
d'immigration était totalement
anarchique depuis des années que on n'a
rien maîtrisé et que du coup on se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans une situation
où l'immigration est trop importante on
a largement dépassé le seuil de
tolérance dans ce domaine et ça a des
conséquences évidemment sur
l'aggravation de l'insécurité sur l'
équilibre de notre site de notre système
social notamment sur nos budgets et donc
moi ce que je souhaite faire c'est faire
ce qui n'a pas été fait depuis 40 ans
c'est à dire écouter les français et
donc je vais mettre en oeuvre dès mon
élection à référendum sur l'immigration
je vais leur dire voilà je vous soumets
un projet de loi et vous pouvez voter
oui où vous pouvez voter non dans ce
projet de loi c'est vrai qu'il ya des
mesures qui sont des mesures fermes
c'est à dire c'est la suppression du
droit du sol je pense qu'on peut plus
avoir on peut pu acquérir la nationalité
française de manière automatique il faut
la mériter on pourra laquelle la keller
mais il faut mériter cette nationalité
française ou bien sûr en hériter mais ça
c'est le droit on enverra les
délinquants et les criminels dans leur
pays parce que quand on a bénéficié de
l'hospitalité dans un pays eh bien on ne
viole pas les lois je veux dire et on
n'agresse pas les gens et on ne vole
rien enfin bon ça c'est sa part et du
bon sens on
n'arrêtera le regroupement familial
on limitera les on arrêtera les
conventions qui sont passés qu'un
certain nombre de pays et qui donne des
conditions d'accès aux nôtres qui sont
beaucoup trop laxiste et on dira une
sauce simple si vous venez vous devez
subvenir à vos propres besoins c'est à
dire soit il faut travailler soit il
faut avoir un patrimoine mais la
communauté nationale ne peut plus
subvenir aux besoins des gens qui
viennent dans notre pays ça veut dire
que pour une toute une série de l'aide
sociale et notamment de mes
contributions de solidarité
ah et bien
il faudra avoir été présent et avoir
travaillé pendant cinq ans en équivalent
temps plein en france pour pouvoir y
avoir accès c'est le cas de la pl c'est
le cas du rsa et d'un certain nombre
d'autres aides qui ne sont pas
contributive c'est à dire c'est pas
celle vers lequel on court bon on cotise
en fait vous avez un membre du
gouvernement fasse de vous marlène
schiappa
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire comme
reproche
à la politique d' emmanuel macron sur
l'immigration mais rien n'a été fait on
a continué exactement comme avant à peu
près avec le même nombre d'ailleurs de
d'entrée sur le territoire avec à peu
près le même nombre de régularisations
avec à peu près le même nombre de
nationalisation avec à peu près le même
nombre de
de droit d'asile moi je change par
exemple la procédure de droit d'asile je
pense que quand si vous voulez il ya un
nombre de demandes d'asile qui est très
importante mais qui a que 25 % de ces
demandes d'asile qui sont autorisés par
les les structures adéquates on ne peut
pas accepter que les trois quarts qui se
sont vu refuser le droit d'asile restent
sur le territoire c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pour moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que le droit d'asile soit demandée
dans nos consulats ou et nos ambassades
n'importe quel consulat et n'importe
quelle ambassade du monde pour qu'elles
soient analysées à ce moment là et ceux
qui ont le droit d'asile ceux à qui on
accorde le droit d'asile pourront alors
rejoindre le territoire national ce qui
évitera d'avoir des gens qui en réalité
reste là et qu'ils ne sont jamais
expulsé parce que les chiffres des
expulsions c'est pareil les occuper
c'est à dire une obligation de quitter
le territoire sur exactement même niveau
aujourd'hui qui hier à savoir un niveau
dérisoire qui est de 10 ou 12% alors
marlène schiappa pourra vous répondre ce
que l étau ministère l'intérieur
maintenant marlène schiappa qu'est ce
que vous répondez à marine le pen sur
quand elle dit que vous n'avez rien fait
sur l'immigration bon d'accord c'est
évidemment un peu caricatural et je suis
bien sûr en désaccord avec un certain
nombre de points qui ont été abordés
d'abord sur l' approche globale je veux
dire que la politique migratoire et
d'immigration à des manuels macron elle
se situe dans un équilibre entre
l'humanité et la fermeté l'humanité
vis-à-vis des personnes que nous devons
accueillir et gère viendrait tout à
l'heure avec la question de l'asile et
la fermeté avec ceux qui n'ont pas
vocation à rester sur notre sol et nous
ne voulons pas regarder les gens pour ce
qu'ils sont pour l'endroit d'où ils
viennent mais pour ce qu'ils font et
c'est pour ça que j'avais obtenu par
exemple dans le comité interministériel
sur l'immigration et l'intégration
l'expulsion des étrangers coupables de
violences conjugales ou de violences
sexuelles je suis très clair là-dessus
et de la même manière nous avons fait
avec le président de la république la
naturalisation vous parliez madame le
pen des chiffres de naturalisation c'est
vrai qu'il y en a eu par ce que nous
avons souhaité naturaliser les
travailleurs coded ces personnes qui
pendant le confinement ont tenu à bout
de bras la république vous savez ces
livreurs c'est nous ces agents de
sécurité de nettoyage ces soignants qui
ont tenu le payer bras certains étaient
de nationalité autre que française nous
en avons naturalisé 17000 ensuite sur la
question de l'asile que je veux bien
distinguer du reste qu'est ce que c'est
que les nazis c'est un des grands
principes fondateurs lié à l'histoire de
l'europe bercé dans le préambule de la
constitution 46 toute personne qui est
combattant de la liberté a le droit de
trouver refuge dans la république
française et l'europe elle s'est
construit comme ça c'est en vertu de
cela que nous accueillons aujourd'hui
des familles ukrainienne voilà justement
je voudrais évoquer le sujet parce que
c'est celui actuel donc allez-y
absolument mais j'étais hier avec le
président de la république emmanuel
macron avec le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin nous étions près de
famille kényane qui nous racontent à
quel point elle fuit la guerre elle fuit
les horreurs qui sont perpétrés
aujourd'hui par la russie en ukraine et
je crois que quand on est un apatride
quand on est un exilé quand on est un
réfugié de guerre est bien la france
doit pouvoir vous accueillir et vous
ouvrir les bras moi je resterai toujours
marqué par cette maman qu'on a rencontré
hier qui nous a raconté qu'elle a passé
la frontière à pied avec sa fille de 10
ans poursuit pour fuir cette ce pays qui
est son pays de coeur où elle a laissé
son père son mari ses frères et pour
venir trouver asile en france et elle
nous a remerciés pas que nous le
gouvernement elle a remercié la france
parce qu'un immense élan de générosité
des français qui sont très
majoritairement d'accord pour accueillir
ces réfugiés qui viennent d'ukraine et
pour leur offrir l'accueil le plus digne
c'est ce qui mobilise comme ministre
j'étais encore tout à l'heure avec
l'ensemble de nos collègues nous avons
ouvert la cellule interministérielle de
crise pour pouvoir leur trouver à chacun
un hébergement digne et un
accompagnement grâce notamment aux
grandes associations que je veux saluer
france terre d'asile france horizon
aurore adoma et toutes les autres qui
jour et nuit vous dans les gares dans
les aéroports accueillir ces femmes et
ces enfants puisque vous le savez ce
sont dans l'immense majorité des femmes
et des enfants qui arrivent en france
bon ben moi j'ai aucun problème à
l'exposition sur le sujet ça mais j'ai
aucun problème avec ça louis aliot quel
maire de perpignan est même allé à la
frontière polonaise pour aller chercher
des femmes et des enfants et des
personnes âgées pour les ramener à
perpignan je n'ai aucun souci avec ça et
d'ailleurs là on est vraiment confrontés
à des gens qui
mérite au sens des textes le droit
d'asile ce sont des réfugiés garr
d'ailleurs 100 % vont obtenir le
problème c'est le détournement depuis
des années de ce droit d'asile c'est à
dire que et on le voit bien d'ailleurs
on le voit bien dans les gens qui a
qu'ils sont accordé trois quarts de ceux
qui le demandent en réalité ne
l'obtiennent pas pourquoi parce que ce
ne sont pas des gens qui devraient
relever du droit d'asile ce sont des
gens qui sont des migrants économiques
et désolé de vous dire madame schiappa
que évidemment ça a sauté aux yeux de
tout le monde que les vagues de
demandeurs d'asile
entre guillemets qu'on a pu avoir dans
les dernières années et dont trois
cartes se sont fait débouter étaient
essentiellement des jeunes hommes on
voit bien que les gens qui fuient la
guerre ce sont évidemment et c'est tout
à fait cohérent d'abord des femmes
d'abord des enfants d'abord des
personnes âgées donc vous voyez que les
français ils sont capables de faire la
différence encore une fois et
s'apercevoir que lorsqu'il ya des gens
qui méritent d'avoir la protection
temporaire de la force parce que ce
qu'on espère tous évidemment que la paix
revienne et qu'il puisse rejoindre leur
père leur frère leur mari bon et mais
les français sont tous d'accord avec ça
il ya zéro difficulté le problème c'est
que les français et ils ont raison on le
sentiment que au fur et à mesure du
temps on a dévoyé en fait des des droits
on a dévoyé des textes pour abuser de
l'eau de leur hospitalité et c'est vrai
et le problème c'est que on accueille
ces gens mais on ne met pas à côté les
moyens parce que moi je vais regarder un
petit peu sur l'hôpital c'est un sujet
majeur l'hôpital on l'a vu pendant la
crise du coc vide monsieur darmana a dit
la dernière fois il ya sept cent mille
clandestins en france bon ce cfa 10 des
dix neuf cent mille moi je peux pas me
battre sur les chiffres mais six à sept
cent mille clandestins il aurait fallu
alors à ce moment là pour pouvoir les
soigner parce qu'on les soigne un bon
moi je suis contre la m e sauf pour les
enfants évidemment les cas où il ya un
danger pour la vie mais il aurait fallu
créer deux chu de plus c'est à dire que
1200 lits d'hôpital de plus pour les
sauniers or vous en avez supprimé 17
milan 5 ans donc après on dit mais ça
pose un problème bah oui ça pose un
problème ça pose un problème parce qu'on
a été vous accueillez vous accueillez
vous accueillez mais que en face mais
les services publics et biens ne peuvent
pas suivre donc ça en bouteille
l'hôpital ça en bouteille
toute une série de services publics
aujourd'hui du coup n'arrivent plus à
faire face et bien moi je pense que ça
c'est une politique de gribouille et qui
sont les victimes de ce là bas ce sont
les français donc revenons à une
politique raisonnable où on peut
accueillir des gens encore faut-il que
il se comporte bien que hills et le soin
le souhait de contribuer à la richesse
du pays parce que mais juste moi vous me
dites il ya des gens qui aident les gens
travaillent oui bien sûr il ya des gens
qui travaillent maintenant je suis assez
d'accord d'ailleurs pour que l'on puisse
éventuellement naturalisés des gens qui
ont travaillé en première ligne pendant
la crise du coc vide et c'est moins cher
je je je leur apporte ce mérite là il ya
aucun paramètre quand vous dites des
maisons des gens qui se comportent bien
ça veut dire quoi se dire que par
exemple la hyène et on va cuire une
personne elle va s comporte bien le
reste et puis un moment ci est ce
comportement l'on voit là mais ça c'est
clair à ses canaux pour moi la vouloir à
mais pour moi les choses sont
extrêmement claires quand on vient dans
un pays où vit avec une épée de damoclès
sur la tête on a barré mais quand on
vient dans un pays on respecte les lois
du pays voilà on vous a offert
l'hospitalité
c'est déjà je trouve quand même très
bien il n'est pas question d'accepter
que des gens viennent chez nous pour
viol idée loi commettent des délits
commettre des crimes et pour le coup
j'étais parfaitement d'accord avec
marlène schiappa quand elle a dit je ne
sais pas d'ailleurs si ça a été fait ou
pas que les agresseurs sexuels devaient
immédiate sûrs et renvoyer ses heures
mais je pense que tous doivent être
renvoyés chez eux je veux dire les
voleurs les violeurs les ce qui
brutalise ceux qui agressent enfin nous
n'avons aucune andres accessible aux
ennemis mais oui parce que c'est la
règle du jeu vous arrivez vous n'êtes
pas chez vous vous arrivez dans un pays
qui vous accueille vous respectez les
gens qui vous accueille c'est à mon avis
la moindre des choses marlène chapin ça
on le fait pour répondre à votre
question on a reconduit expulsé selon le
vocabulaire choisi puis donné 300
personnes l'année dernière qui étaient
des personnes qui sont rendus coupables
de troubles à l'ordre public ou de
violence contre les femmes et c'est sur
l'aim sur l'aide médicale d'état on a un
vrai désaccord profond de fond et vous
avez le mérite de la cohérence parce que
c'est vrai que votre parti demande à
chaque fois la suppression du budget de
l'aide médicale d'état à titre personnel
et en tant que ministre qui suis chargé
de l'intégration et notamment de
l'accueil des réfugiés mais aussi de
l'intégration des personnes qui viennent
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est
fondamental de conserver l'aide médicale
d'état parce qu'on est en france et en
france quand les gens sont malades on
les soigne on les renvoie pas à la porte
de l'hôpital nous ne sommes pas dans un
pays où la santé est une valeur
marchande quand quelqu'un est malade on
le soigne d'abord pour lui même c'est
une question d'humanité et de fraternité
et puis pour des questions de santé
publique ça veut dire que si vous avez
des personnes qui arrivent d'autres pays
et qui souffrent de maladies vous ne va
pas soigner on va laisser des épidémies
se propageait donc là et me pour moi
elle est fondamentale nous sommes en
france une terre d'asile et quand les
gens arrivent en france ils sont malades
on les soigne les personnes qui arrivent
d'ukraine nous leur proposons une
vaccination pour le crès dalle est
d'accord avec moi mais ça n'a rien à
voir alors ne me choque pas ce sont là
les blessés pour les clandestins s'est
passé pourquoi j'étais d'accord
justement alors les gens qui viennent du
crâne sont pas réfugié je voudrais très
précises dans les terres vous avez dit à
plusieurs reprises les redskins ont pas
réfugié pour avoir le statut de réfugié
il faut faire une demande à l'ofpra et
d'une part ça prend plusieurs mois pour
avoir une réponse même si on travaille
pour réduire les délais de réponse aux
demandes d'asile d'une part et puis
d'autre part comme vous le savez quand
vous avez un statut de réfugié vous ne
pouvez pas retourner dans le pays d'où
vous êtes réfugiés puisqu'on considère
que vous êtes menacés donc à la demande
de gérald darmanin au nom de la france
nous avons au niveau européen dans le
cadre de la présidence française de
l'union européenne créé un nouveau
statut qui est un statut de protection
temporaire qui donne à ces personnes
venues d'ukraine la possibilité circuler
dans l'union européenne le droit de
travailler et c'est fondamental parce
que beaucoup nous disent nous voulons
travailler j'étais avec le consul
d'ukraine à la gare pour accueillir des
familles il nous a dit vous savez les
familles qui viennent elles veulent
pouvoir travailler c'est pour ça qu'on
s'organise pour que les enfants soient
pris en charge qu'ils soient scolarisés
parce que je crois que l'intégration ça
passe aussi par le travail par les
relations par l'apprentissage de la les
intégrer d'avoir un accès aux soins et
ça c'est extrêmement nommé madame
m'échappe pas ils sont réfugiés ils ont
une protection temporaire au passage
d'ailleurs il ya des familles qui
s'interrogent aujourd'hui qui les ont
accueillis qui s'interrogent de savoir
comment est ce qu'elles vont continuer
d'ailleurs à leur venir en aide parce
que pour l'instant c'est vrai car rien
de précis qui fait évidemment ils ont
ils sont soignés par le pays au bénéfice
de cette protection mais y'a pas les
intégrer madame chapa ils veulent pas
rester en france ils veulent rentrer
chez eux il veut que la paix est arrivé
que il faut voir rentrer chez eux la fin
de la guinée ont donné jeudi
objectivement du temps et que ces
personnes pour l'instant il sans visage
pas si vous voulez sur le long terme et
c'est contre l'intégration des étrangers
qui viennent en france madame le pen
c'est une arme est d'abord d'avoir
raison de l'intégration je suis pour la
simulation déjà mais ça c'est un autre
sujet dont on pourrait parler parce que
je pense qu'à une grosse différence
entre la simulation et l'intégration
c'est parce qu'elle veut travailler on
va les aider à pouvoir travailler à
pouvoir faire garder leurs enfants on ne
sait pas si elles sont là en transit
pour aller en espagne mercuriale où il
ya beaucoup plus de personnes qui
viennent l'ukraine on sait pas si elles
vont bien sûr mais sur les hébergements
citoyens si vous permettez que ce que
vous mmes interpellé sur ces familles
qui accueillent et je les salue et je
salue tous les maires quelle que soit
leur couleur politique y compris bien
sûr ceux de votre mouvement parce que
c'est extrêmement important on a besoin
que les maires s'engagent avec nous et
je remercie tous ceux de tout
l'échiquier politique qui le font
aujourd'hui nous avons créé une
plateforme qui s'appelle parrainage pour
réfugiés point info sous la bannière je
m'engage pour l'ukraine à des familles
françaises j'en termine qui permet à des
familles françaises d'accueillir des
familles ukrainienne je veux le dire ici
nous remercions ces personnes mais cela
doit être encadré il doit y avoir une
intermédiation des associations et des
travailleurs sociaux des services de
l'état parce qu'il ya comme dans tout
mouvement déplacement des risques des
risques de violence des risques de
traite des êtres humains tant pour
protéger les familles françaises que ces
personnes vulnérables qui viennent
d'ukraine il faut passer par cette
plateforme parrainage pour réfugiés
point fort qui permet à chacun d'être
accompagné dans son élan de générosité